AND TRUMP LOYALEST WHO THE
PRESIDENT THREATENED TO INSTALL
AS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED?
>> FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS RAIDED
THE HOME OF JEFFREY CLARK
YESTERDAY.
HE WAS AN ENVIRONMENTAL LAWYER
AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
NOBODY REALLY KNEW HIS NAME
UNTIL IN THE CLOSING DAYS OF
2020 EARLY 2021, PRESIDENT TRUMP
AT THE TIME WAS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO INSTALL HIM AT THE
HEAD OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
HE WANTED TO MAKE HIM ATTORNEY
GENERAL, BECAUSE HE WAS WILLING
TO CARRY OUT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S WISHES TO SEND
LETTERS TO THE STATES
ESSENTIALLY SAYING THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT BELIEVED THAT
THERE WAS SUFFICIENT FRAUD TO
INVESTIGATE.
THIS WAS OBVIOUSLY CENTRAL TO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S EFFORT TO
ESSENTIALLY SET ASIDE JOE
BIDEN'S VICTORY AND TO GET THE
STATES TO SEND THESE FAKE
ELECTORS, AND FIND A WAY FOR
TRUMP TO REMAIN IN POWER.
AND SO CLARK WAS WILLING TO DO
THAT.
THERE WAS THIS EXTRAORDINARY
MEET AGENT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ON A SUNDAY.
JANUARY 3RD, A COUPLE DAYS
BEFORE JANUARY 6TH.
WHERE JEFFREY CLARK AND JEFFREY
ROSEN WHO WAS THE ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL AT THE TIME
ESSENTIALLY WERE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE FOR HOURS AS TRUMP SORT OF
LORDED OVER THIS APPRENTICE
STYLE COMPETITION BETWEEN
JEFFREY CLARK AND JEFFREY ROSEN.
WHO WAS GOING TO BE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AT THE END OF THAT DAY.
IT WASN'T UNTIL SEVERAL OF THE
OFFICIALS INCLUDING THE PEOPLE
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM TODAY,
RICHARD DONAHUE, THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL AT THE TIME.
STEVE ENGLE WHO WAS THE HEAD OF
THE OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL,
THEY SAID TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, LOOK, YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE MASS RESIGNATION.
EVERYONE IS GOING TO RESIGN.
NO ONE IS GOING TO STAY IN
OFFICE AND WORK UNDER JEFFREY
CLARK IF YOU DO THIS.
IN THE END, TRUMP DIDN'T DO
THIS.
BUT CLARK WAS DEFINITELY READY
TO DO THIS.
HE PROPROSED, WRITTEN LETTERS,
PROPOSED LETTERS THAT WERE GOING
TO BE SENT TO GEORGIA AND OTHER
STATES SAYING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WAS INVESTIGATING
FRAUD.
OBVIOUSLY THEY WERE LOOKING INTO
SOME OF THESE CLAIMS BUT HAD
FOUND NOTHING TO SUBSTANTIATE
IT.
>> SO THE RAID BY AUTHORITIES
IS -- DO WE KNOW WHAT THEY
FOUND?
>> WE DON'T KNOW YET WHAT THEY
FOUND.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED YESTERDAY.
AND AT THIS POINT, WE KNOW THAT
THE -- THESE WERE FEDERAL AGENTS
THAT DID THIS.
THIS MEANS, OBVIOUSLY, THAT
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT JEFFREY
CLARK IS AT THE CENTER OF, THAT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
INVESTIGATING.
AND THAT WHATEVER EVIDENCE IS
INSIDE THAT -- INSIDE HIS HOME,
WHICH IS IN NORTHERN VIRGINIA,
IS OF INTEREST TO INVESTIGATORS
AND THAT THEY BELIEVE THEY
COULDN'T JUST GO ASK HIM FOR IT.
RIGHT?
THEY HAD TO BELIEVE THEY HAD TO
MAKE THE CASE TO A JUDGE THAT
THERE WAS SOME RISK THAT SIMPLY
ASKING HIM FOR THE INFORMATION
THERE COULD BE DEDESTRUCTION OF
EVIDENCE AND SO ON.
THAT'S THE REASON.
THAT'S THE WAY YOU GET TO THIS
EXTRAORDINARY STEP THAT YOU'D
HAVE A RAID BY FEDERAL AGENTS ON
A FORMER TOP JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL.
AGAIN, SOMEBODY WHO WAS AT THE
CENTER OF THIS EFFORT BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT TO SORT OF USE
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO KIND
OF FIND A WAY TO REMAIN IN
POWER.
I SHOULD SAY THE ATTORNEY OFFICE
IN WASHINGTON WHICH IS
OVERSEAING THE JANUARY 6TH
INVESTIGATIONS TOLD ME THAT THEY
COULD ONLY CONFIRM THAT THERE
WAS INVESTIGATIVE ACTIVITY IN
THE VICINITY OF JEFFREY CLARK'S
HOME.
THEY CAN'T DISCLOSE THE NAME AND
WHAT WAS OCCURRING.
BUT WE KNOW FROM MULTIPLE
SOURCES THIS OCCURRED YESTERDAY.
>> HAS HE SPOKEN TO THE
JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE?
>> HE SHOWED UP BUT DECLINED TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SO AGAIN, WE DON'T KNOW VERY
MUCH ABOUT HIS STORY BECAUSE HE
HAS REALLY NOT TOLD A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT EXACTLY
HE WAS THINKING ABOUT.
AND WHY HE WAS INTERESTED IN
DOING THIS.
WHEN EVERYONE AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WAS TELLING HIM THAT
THERE WAS NO PROOF OF SOME OF
THE CRAZY IDEAS.
HE CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA THAT
HE WANTED THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TO LOOK INTO WHETHER ITALIAN
SATELLITES WERE CHANGING VOTE
TOTALS.
THERE WERE ALL KINDS OF THINGS
THAT JEFFREY ROSEN HAD TO DEAL
WITH THIS GUY THAT HE HAD REALLY
HAD VERY LITTLE INTERACTION WITH
UNTIL THE CLOSING DAYS OF
DECEMBER 2020.
>> IF MEMORY SERVES, JEFFREY
ROSEN THREATENED TO RESIGN.
>> TRUMP WAS PLANNING TO REPLACE
ROSEN WITH CLARK.
SO DONAHUE